MARCH TWENTY ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
WE HAVE THIRTY BILLS CONSIDER
THIS MORNING AND WE ALSO HAVE
SEVERAL MEMBERS ABSENT SO I'D
LIKE TO THINK.
AT SOME POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
FRIEDMAN AND JONES SAWYER.
I'M STILL LEARNING HIS ON THIS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
FOR SORRY TESTING.
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT --
I WE WE ARE GOING TO CONVENE AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE ARE
WAITING ON ONE MORE PERSON TO
JOIN US IN IN THE MEANTIME.
MR MATHIS AB.
TWO OH TWO THIS ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
I'LL KEEP IT SHORT MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB TWO OH TWO WILL SIMPLY REMOVE
THE SUNSET ON THE SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENT PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IN RESTORING --
HABITAT FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES
--
THE SUN SAID --
WILL FARTHER AID --
SPECIES RECOVERY THAT IS
THREATENED.
SO I JUST SIMPLY ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORTER AND TO KEEP THIS.
VITAL PROGRAM TO CONTINUE.
I'LL WITHOUT CAUSING ANY UPSET
GIVEN SECURITY FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE REACH THESE AGREEMENTS WITH
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR A QUORUM THE
BILL.
AS I TOLD YOU TO ENTER
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
JUST A LITTLE NOT ON THE MY GAME
TODAY -- DO
YOU HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE HERE ON BEHALF HUMBOLDT
REDWOOD COMPANY AND ALSO MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS.
ARE YOU COME UP IN SUPPORT OF
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEN NONE.
I FINANCES IN HERE.
DOES ANYONE HAVE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
DOCTOR PARK.
CAN YOU ADD ME AS A CO AUTHOR.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
IF YOU HOLD FOR JUST ONE MOMENT
--
LIST I WISH A QUORUM AND THEN WE
CAN HOPEFULLY TAKE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL [inaudible]
MA'AM SECRETARY [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
ROOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CARILLO.
JONES SAWYER THEIR DEEP.
HERE EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
APRIL.
GARCIA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
THE NORSE.
WORK HERE PREVIOUS [inaudible]
EXACTLY.
THE MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN MEMBERS ANDJUST ASK --
FOR FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS SO
WE CAN KEEP THIS PROGRAM GOING
SO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH ENDANGERED SPECIES.
GREAT THANK INTENT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE ONLY HAVE ONE OTHER
BILL PRESENTATION OR EXPECTING
TODAY AND THAT'S BY MR TEAMS SO
IF ANYONE FROM HIS OFFICE IS
WATCHING IF YOU COULD --
LOOK AT THAT.
THAT'S THE WAY WE DO THINGS
HERE.
TEAM PLAYER THIS CREE IS GOING
TO PRESENT A MISTER TEAMS BILL
IT'S A. B. FIFTY FOUR ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THINK OF A THE MOTION.
YEAH CHAU MOVED.
I HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN I
DON'T THINK YOU WILL THEIR WORK
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE IT'S THE BILL TO CLARIFY --
AN ERROR IN THE DRAFT.
A DRAFT AND ARE THERE ANY OF
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
--
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND LIKE
IT'S OUT ON AND I'M SORRY ISRAEL
HAS A QUESTION THAT HOPEFULLY
SHE CAN ANSWER.
MY QUESTION WAS REALLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
NORMALLY HAVE A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THRESHOLD AND
THIS BILL WAS HEARD ONCE BEFORE.
HAD A OF THE PROJECT COST OF IN
EXCESS OF A MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD JUST CURIOUS WHY.
THIS WAS MINE UNTIL RIPPLE AND
I'LL JUST LEAVE THAT COMMENT
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE I KNOW THE
AUTHOR WAS HERE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
SO I APPRECIATED I THINK THE
ORIGINAL BILL COST THAT MUCH OF
THIS IS JUST A FIX TO THE
ORIGINAL BILL SO I WAS TRYING TO
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT AN
ADDITIONAL FEE.
WANT TO MAKE SURE I WAS CLEAR
SO.
BEFORE VOTE ON IT LOOKS LIKE IT.
THAT'S COOL ALL RIGHT THINKING
THIS BILL WITH THAT THAT GETS
OUT ON ANY ROLL CALL WITH MR
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU MISS GRAHAM THANK YOU
AT THIS POINT --
WE WILL ASK THE MA'AM SECRETARY
TO READ THE CONSENT AGENDA.
AB 692-923-9290 NINE IN AB FIFTY
SEVEN WITH THE MINUTES. TO A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT AGENDA SO
MOVE.
A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
THE SECOND TIME IS CARILLO THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL --
NOW IF MEN SECRETARY PLEASE.
LIST OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AB 281-351-40140 215-864-1652
009-215-2272 TWO TWO TWO THREE
OR 431-331-7320 333-337-3393
824-024-15420 FIVE AND FOUR
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU IF ANYBODY
HERE WISHES TO TEST RAN A BILL
THAT WAS MOVED TO THE SAYS FENCE
FILE IN THE AUTHOR WAY
PRESENTATION WHICH EVERY AUTHOR
DEAD BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY GOOD
AUTHORS --
YOU ARE WELCOME TO COME FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR POSITION ON ANY
OF THE BILLS THAT WERE MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE WHILE.
SIR ANYBODY HERE.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE THAT
CONCLUDES TODAY'S APPROPRIATIONS
MEETING